the Joe Rogan experience have you ever
thought about a boxing match like
you see have you really I actually
thought I was going to instead of MMA I
actually wanted the box really yeah cuz
I was living at the Olympic Training
Center and and my girlfriend at the time
was an Olympic boxer and oh yeah and so
I was like man this wrestling thing is
not really working out because I've been
hurt a few times and it's hurting my
motivation to want to be Olympic
champion wrestler so I can tell my
motivation was starting to die down and
I'm like what else can I do like I'm but
I still want to compete and of course
you know dating a boxer and I mean just
kind of watched him now you start to be
engulfed in what they're doing in the
preparation and I'm deeply enriched in
it now to where and I was already a
boxing fan but now I might she's
starting to learn what's going on and
I'm like maybe I should just come back
and box for the next four years and try
to make the Olympic team and go with
Neela Biggs but then I might wait so I'm
gonna throw away this skill that I just
weren't spent ten almost ten years
perfecting and learning just throw that
away and then just start a new sport off
the rib
you're an idiot how old were you at the
time I'm I'm in what 20 23 24
so now you've been striking for many
many years now yeah and so when you see
something happen like with Conor and
Floyd Mayweather yeah if something like
that comes your way would I take it
regularly absolutely know that the issue
that the thing with that is a lot of
people are going to say no you can't box
I you can't box like these guys know
this at the end of the day no I'm not
conditioned to being able to box like
them to be able to go 12 three-minute
rounds even though yes MMA rounds of
five minute rounds might be more intense
in those three minute rounds but it's
different conditioning yeah to be able
to slip punches move and then throw
punches and block punch and be efficient
be efficient comfortable it's it's a
it's man it's hard work to where we go
MMA fight we go into boxing you do fall
around you feel like you want to die hmm
there were a box you can come into you
know MMA and
might not even be able to get through
around right you know it's just
different mechanics you know just being
able to work the mind and relax the mind
to get the work done it's different yes
- Nadine I would definitely give it a I
would definitely give it a try because I
mean that's that's part of being a
champion is taking on new challenges and
going out there and giving it your best
shot
well a fight like that would be Canelo
right because Canelo just one 175-pound
tiger you should throw me to the wolves
I mean that would be the big fight I
mean I'm not trying to throw you to the
game with you the big that big Floyd
Mayweather money to fight Canelo look if
they started doing [ __ ] like that I
would give it I would give it my all I I
think I would take that absolutely would
you really yeah I think I would take
would you like one fight first though
would you like a boxing match first
before you cuz I think like Conor
wouldn't hunter fought Floyd Floyd I
would yeah but I would of course I would
spar with I get some some big-time boxes
in there to spar with me and it really
helped me prepare how much time would
you need cuz what I'm saying is like
Floyd was a janello he gave he gave
Conor a very short window time to get
ready yeah Floyd was like yeah I'll give
you like six hunters master but but
Floyd to master he's a mastermind yeah
that's his game that's his world he
knows what he's doing if you were gonna
fight a real like legit boxer can now
look Jacob someone like that yeah Jacob
six months six months yeah six months
six months to be confident in my
preparation to just go out there and do
it I mean yeah of course I could do it
in less time but but six months for me
to do it right to feel confident going
in there to box a boxer not and not
saying that I I would definitely win no
it's me I'm gonna give it my all like
I'm gonna coming you not finna just walk
over me you're gonna fill me here now
I'm not trying to set you up with a big
fight but when I'm saying is what with
Zuffa boxing right now because the UFC
is getting involved in box absolutely
and they do have some plans on promoting
some big boxing matches and perhaps
having some crossover fights like
Crawford is talking about fighting he's
like I'll fight you one boxing match
with Conor he's like I'll fight you one
boxing match and we'll fight you one MMA
match I think he can do it
I think Terrence could do anything I
mean you see his kid his kid's arrested
yes yes yeah you can rest you know
from Omaha you you from you know that
Midwest you touched him at a couple of
times you've wrestled a bit and his
hands dude that guy and that guy
switches up as good as anybody on the
planet that's the thing I was gonna say
is you know that's the guy that I like
to watch a lot to boxing he's and harder
to learn some you know here's some
things from him
yeah he's the way he's very good he's an
orthodox fighter when he switches
southpaw he's deadly he's just as good
just get me not better yeah he can do
anything and he's like a computer he's
yes starts seeing where there's openings
find you weaknesses and then starts
putting it on you and putting it on you
yeah Terrence is special he's got a dog
in him too yes oh yeah she loves it he
loves it that's something that a lot of
people might not take away but when he
turns on that dog you're in trouble yeah
no he's special I could do it I think he
could too I just don't know if he's
famous enough to entice you know like
not not make him Floyd in Conor me right
right I mean who knows I mean maybe
Connor wants to have a bunch of it made
me look Connors got probably 100 million
dollars in the bank right he probably
he's doing if he's doing it right now
he's barely doing it for the money
anyway he's doing it for the challenge
and for the rise yeah it might be
something that he would be interested in
but he just said he wants to Billy I
think you did well enough could get
there I mean they they posted his
earnings the other day on one of the
paper views that we just did and they
were saying these already made more than
200 million dollars in his career
yeah well that's that's a fifth of the
way yeah yeah no I think I definitely
think he can do it up bill bill I mean
I'm shooting for two 250 250 million yes
too many feel like I think to fit not
retired I'm gonna do other jobs as well
but 250 million I think because at that
point it's generational wealth oh yeah
it's something that you know my kids
kids and my family is going to be able
to live off of
that's dynasty money yeah that's that's
that's all I care about
[Applause]